so yes the talk is true daredevil in
season 3 has his black suit again the
ninja suit the tights doesn't have his
red suit which damn it that means are
gonna make a hot toys of this daredevil
which is a daredevil hot toys I really
wanted so I'm gonna have to get that one
now more money but glad the black suits
back
[Music]
daredevil season 3 so daredevil season 3
is the newest season of daredevil on
Netflix takes place after the defenders
Matt Murdock's in a bit of a different
place now I first physically throughout
the season mentally up to this point
he's been Matt Murdock lawyer by day
daredevil by night but in this season he
has just given up the life of Matt
Murdock he's like Matt Murdock was a lie
I am the daredevil so he's daredevil by
night daredevil without the ninja outfit
during the day it's actually a really
sweet twist and taken it's something
that shows for season 3 the best shows I
can think of usually in season 3 they do
something to do something to switch it
up to flip it on its head you can't keep
the same structure and formula forever
you have to do something that's what
season 3 it is at first I was really put
off by it I'm like how interesting can
that be
I like season 1 with you know daredevil
Matt Murdock and friends but it totally
worked for season 3 I am so glad to see
Vincent D'Onofrio back as Wilson Fisk I
love his Wilson Fisk in this season he's
got the white suit you just look at him
when he's talking you're like that's him
that's the guy that is as Wilson Fisk as
Wilson Fisk could ever be like this
perfect casting and I really loved the
story unless in this season's telling
like he's on house arrest granted in a
penthouse but still house arrest the FBI
is looking over him there's no way this
guy can be any threat whatsoever but
it's Wilson Fisk and what he's doing and
how he does it it's brilliant and it
really shows how unstoppable this guy is
and he's doing it for love also yes
Wilson Fisk is back but we have
ourselves another villain bull's-eyes in
it I didn't know bullseye was gonna be
in this season I've kept my nose out of
daredevil season 3 tock well one thing
happens where you're like pretty sure
that's bullseye but I really love
bull's-eyes arc 2 it's really a tragic
title I mean granted he's a dick but his
life is a tragedy and it really shows
how Wilson Fisk he's a manipulator he
sees what you need he forms that bond in
relationship between you there doesn't
mean [ __ ] to him it just it's a means to
an end you are a tool and now he's got
you that doesn't work he'll just
blackmail the [ __ ] out of you but
usually that's how he does other than
bull's-eyes story being compelling
bullseye as a villain menacing as hell
and that's what I really love about what
Netflix daredevil has always done it
takes a character hero or villain and
shows the best version of that character
Netflix daredevil can take the dorkiest
character ever be like will make them
killer and this ice ain't bull's-eyes
dorky I'm just saying I'm just saying
there's just that talented bull's eye if
he didn't know is a crack shot he always
hits his target he can take any
inanimate object and make
weapon a projectile weapon anything
think about that think of how menacing
that is a say there's a Throwdown in an
office space
how much clutter and crap is in an
office space all of those are weapons
for bullseye and there's a Throwdown in
here with bull's-eyes essentially the
most annoying boss fight ever any time
Daredevils trying to get out of cover he
can't just something whizzes by him it's
like you're trapped he's not doing that
he's ricocheting bullets like revolver
ocelot and [ __ ] and hitting people that
way that's the second Metal Gear Solid
reference I've made in two videos I love
those series I'm kind of on a Metal Gear
Solid kick right now that's a really
scary villain it intimidates Matt
Murdock I love it when a villain comes
on scene where the heroes like I haven't
even dealt with something like that
before I so I don't know how to deal
with it there's no playbook I'm learning
as I go and I haven't run into that yet
this is how I learn is going toe-to-toe
with this dude this dude who doesn't
miss guys who didn't kill me from across
the room with pens and pencils and this
great it keeps his series feeling fresh
new exciting and not stagnant also the
fight choreography daredevil is so good
at framing up a shot and not cutting
away too soon it doesn't just put cut
cut cut cut cut like you know I do in my
videos I'm trying to get a lot of verbal
information to you and the quickest
amount of time possible I feel like that
works for that but not a fight scene I
just love the fact that daredevil
generally and usually keeps the fight
shot going for long enough for you to
see what's going on and of course in
daredevil tradition there is a shot
that's just one tracking shot through an
uncut fight and it's escalated gotten
more and more and more in season 1 it
was that hallway Season 2 staircase
season 3 is just out of control it goes
from fighting to dialogue to more
fighting to exiting the facility it was
like I don't even know I can't even
comprehend how it was done there a
couple scenes from like a cut could have
been they're still impressive
nonetheless again like I wish MCU movies
would do something like that I feel like
the season does start slow but does it
start slower it retrospectively slow
like it starts out slow in the first
couple episodes sure but I was still
interested as to what was happening with
Matt Murdock so it's not like I was
uninterested it just isn't as exciting
as the rest of the season by the time
the season wraps up and ends you look
back at the first couple episodes you
like oh yeah that was slow when I was
there I didn't feel like it was just
unbearably slow so there is that I feel
like it's a perspective thing at least
for me now because it's concentrating so
much on Matt Murdock and him as
daredevil this time I feel like foggy
kind of gets pushed in the background
not that he doesn't have his own stuff
going on in here but Karen gets more
shine than foggy you see foggy pop up
throughout the season here and there
really comes into important play in the
last couple episode guys in the end if
you like daredevil season 1 I feel like
this season takes it back to what I
loved about season 1 Matt Murdock and
Wilson Fisk toe-to-toe for the soul of
Hell's Kitchen and New York itself
Wilson Fisk is out he is pissed and he
is coming after daredevil he's doing it
through skill manipulation resources
showing that he is how to phrase it he's
just one of the best villains ever but
all-in-all this season masterful it was
great I feel like episode 4 or 5 on it
was just I was like one more episode I
can't go to bed now just one more
episode and after that episode you're
like just well I've gotta sleep I love
it when a season or a show makes me do
that in a binge right so daredevil
season 2 have you seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here
just anymore
[Music]